este vídeo ha sido posible gracias al
surf shark vpn luego estoy más detalles
pero antes vamos con nuestra historia de
hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos de visual político hoy
vamos a hablar de un tema espinoso
porque nos vamos a centrar en la empresa
en la que está alojada visual política y
que tanto vosotros como nosotros estamos
utilizando ahora mismo
hablamos de alphabet
[Música]
y ya sé lo que pensáis pero alphabet no
estáis en youtube
wells y efectivamente estamos en youtube
pero es que youtube forma parte de
google ya su vez google es la principal
filial del conglomerado alphabet y eso
significa que no sólo hablamos de
youtube sino también de google maps de
'google earth' de android de google
drive y de un largo etcétera de empresas
mis queridos amigos de visual política
internet es grande y diverso pero la
mayoría de las empresas formas parte o
dependen de cinco gigantes alphabet es
decir google facebook amazon apple y
microsoft estas cinco grandes empresas
también se les llama cafam o las big tex
y diréis pero dónde está el problema por
ejemplo si no fuera porque existe una
plataforma tan grande como youtube
visual polític no sería posible ni
tampoco ninguno de los canales que tanto
os gustan y que han empezado con unos
amigos como nosotros grabando vídeos su
casa
[Música]
por supuesto podríamos haber montado una
página web pero quién nos conocería sin
un buscador como google
tendríamos que haber gastado miles de
millones de dólares en publicidad para
poder llegar a todos vosotros y eso es
impensable para casi ningún youtuber
todo esto es fantástico pero existe un
riesgo os voy a dar un ejemplo a día de
hoy el buscador google acapara más del
80% del mercado en todo el mundo hay muy
pocos países donde google no sea el
motor de búsqueda dominante
uno de ellos es rusia donde están en
tablas con yandex y el otro es china
donde está prohibido
en el resto del mundo google es el
buscador principal y cuando digo
principal me refiero a que en países tan
dispersos como españa la india o brasil
más del 90% de las búsquedas se hacen a
través de google en otras palabras
podríamos decir que existe un monopolio
de google en las búsquedas y directos
pero esto realmente es un problema pues
depende de cómo lo veamos por un lado
google se ha ganado su posición dando un
servicio fantástico creo que aquí no hay
ninguna duda la pregunta ahora es podría
surgir una empresa que les hiciera a la
competencia muchos pensaréis y quién más
da si se utiliza un buscador u otros y
solo lo usamos para
para todo el buscador es lo primero que
utilizamos antes de entrar en internet
es decir que si algo no aparece en los
primeros resultados de búsquedas de
google podemos decir que es como si no
existiera
esto significa muchísimo poder para
google principio este poder no tiene por
qué ser malo pero a veces puede tener
consecuencias como están
antimonopolio la comisión europea multa
google con 2.420 millones de euros por
abusar de su posición dominante como
motor de búsqueda dando ventajas
ilegales a sus servicios de compras esta
es sólo una de las muchas multas que la
comisión europea ha puesto a google por
lo que llaman abuso de posición de
mercado a día de hoy google está
apelando estás multas en los tribunales
y es que ninguno de estos casos tiene
una respuesta fácil
europa dice que google abusa de su
posición de mercado pero google dice que
tanto su motor de búsqueda como su
sistema operativo android son que son
suyos y es lógico que si tú entras en
una tienda el dueño quiera promover un
producto sobre cualquier otro por la
razón que sea es más google también
permite que otros productos puedan
promocionarse en sus plataformas como
veis hablamos de un debate donde ni
siquiera nosotros en visual político
tenemos una opinión clara y ya sé lo qué
pensaréis muchos y si esto fuera una
estrategia de europa para castigar a una
empresa estadounidense pues lo cierto es
que estas batallas legales no están
únicamente en europa atentos
el departamento de justicia de eeuu y 11
estados acusan a google de infracciones
antimonopolio la demanda acusa a google
de usar su enorme tamaño para
monopolizar ilegalmente el mercado de
publicidad generada por el buscador como
podéis ver esta es una demanda muy
parecida a las que ya había presentado
europa y lo más seguro es que el proceso
judicial vaya para años de nuevo
hablamos de un debate donde no hay una
respuesta fácil antes de seguir tenemos
que decir que google no es la única
empresa que está teniendo batallas
antimonopolio apple facebook o amazon
están sufriendo procesos muy parecidos
pero en este vídeo vamos a centrarnos en
el grupo alfa bet es decir en google
[Música]
así que la pregunta que hoy nos hacemos
es de dónde viene esta batalla legal
hasta qué punto hablamos de razones
económicas o de simples intereses
políticos cómo funciona la legislación
antimonopolio hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes antes vamos a
hablar de la otra cara de internet la
cara más oscura como sabéis este año
2020 mientras todos estábamos en casa
usando internet más que nunca los
ciberataques se han multiplicado desde
estafas hasta saqueos y cómo nos
protegemos contra los hackers exacto con
una vpn y cuál es la vpn favorita de
visual político pues ya lo sabéis todos
porque lo decimos todos los meses sur
shark vpn
vamos a decirlo claro surf shark es una
vpn fantástica y super segura por
ejemplo nos ha pasado alguna vez que
entráis en una página web ellos empiezan
a salir un montón de pop apps de
propaganda esto se llama fishing pues
bien sus art tiene una herramienta que
se llama clean web que bloquea todos
estos popup si todos estos enlaces que
pueden ser un auténtico peligro
pero no sólo eso con una única cuenta de
surf shark podéis registrar todos los
dispositivos que queráis el móvil la
tableta el portátil no hay ningún límite
de dispositivos y como siempre tenemos
una oferta muy especial para todos
vosotros que seguís visual política
básicamente si usáis el código político
tendréis un 84 por ciento de descuento
más cuatro meses extra totalmente gratis
es más podéis probar surf shark durante
los primeros 30 días sin ningún
compromiso en la descripción
os dejo los enlaces y ahora sí vamos a
ver un poco de historia
el gran dilema del capitalismo el
capitalismo es un sistema económico que
se fundamenta en inquietud puedas montar
una empresa y sigas un buen servicio la
gente te irá bien si las un servicio
extraordinariamente bueno pueden llegar
a convertirte en prácticamente el único
proveedor de este servicio
realmente esto no se da tan a menudo
como la gente se piensa de hecho en la
mayor parte de los monopolios que
existen en el mundo son monopolios
generados por los estados en otras
palabras la mayor parte de los
monopolios del planeta son de empresas
públicas por ejemplo en españa renfe
tiene el monopolio de los trenes algunos
servicios postales son un monopolio
estatal en eeuu pero también hay
monopolios que surgen por el propio
sistema de libre mercado y como os
podéis imaginar esto entra en colisión
con otro principio básico del
capitalismo la competencia es decir
mientras haya varias empresas
compitiendo en un campo los productos
irán mejorando en calidad y en precio si
una empresa no ofrece calidad y buen
precio los consumidores se van a otra el
problema si una empresa es demasiado
grande podría llegar a comprar a los
posibles competidores por ejemplo cuando
facebook compro instagram acabo con uno
de sus mayores competidores
es esto bueno o malo para el mercado
pues hay opiniones legítimas para todos
los gustos y aquí es cuando hablamos de
las legislaciones antimonopolio y del
abuso de la posición dominante un
ejemplo de esto sería microsoft si
recordáis en los años 90 microsoft tenía
el monopolio de los sistemas operativos
el 90% de los ordenadores personales de
todo el mundo utilizaban windows así que
la pregunta no era si windows o apple
sino si windows 95 windows 98 vamos que
windows no era un sistema operativo era
el sistema operativo y entonces ocurrió
lo siguiente
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el departamento de justicia presenta una
demanda antimonopolio contra microsoft
por monopolizar ilegalmente los mercados
de software informático esta demanda de
1998 se convirtió en la pesadilla de
bill gates el departamento de justicia
acusaba a microsoft de competencia
desleal cláusulas de exclusividad
ilegales y también de abuso de su
posición dominante al incluir su
navegador internet explorer en el
sistema operativo windows y el resultado
fue éste
se ordena microsoft any vivirse en dos
empresas
efectivamente microsoft tendría que
separarse en dos una empresa encargada
de los sistemas operativos y otra del
software sin embargo microsoft apeló y
llegó un acuerdo menos drástico pero aún
así bastante doloroso aceptaba que las
empresas de la competencia tuvieran
acceso a sus sistemas ya las interfaces
de programación de aplicaciones durante
los cinco años siguientes
[Música]
hoy en día 20 años después de esta
demanda microsoft ya no tiene el
monopolio de los sistemas operativos
apple ha ganado más cuota en el mercado
de la que tenía antes e incluso hay
gente que utiliza más el teléfono móvil
que el ordenador así que entran ahora en
juegos sistemas operativos como android
es decir microsoft sigue siendo una
empresa muy competitiva pero ya no es un
monopolio
y aquí llega la gran pregunta que os
estallará la cabeza habría ocurrido esto
si no hubiera sido por la intervención
del gobierno o tal vez siempre había
habido espacio para nuevas empresas que
le hicieran sombra a microsoft esto os
lo dejo para que los reflexiones pero
ahora vamos con lo que sí podemos
responder de qué le acusan a google
cuáles son los cargos que presentan para
acusarles de prácticas monopolísticas
pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
y bold como todos sabéis google es una
de esas empresas creada por un
inmigrante sergey brin es uno de los
cofundadores de google junto a larry
page y es de origen ruso
en el año 1995 estos dos estudiantes de
stanford idearon el algoritmo básico de
lo que luego sería google tres años
después ya tenían inversores una empresa
constituida bajo el nombre google inc e
incluso su propia sede en un garaje
garaje que por cierto era propiedad de
la que luego sería la ceo de youtube
susan wojcicki por aquel entonces
internet estaba empezando sólo tenía 200
millones de usuarios en todo el mundo
aún así ya existían buscadores como
yahoo
yandex walt a vista y un largo etcétera
muchos de ellos incluso se anunciaban
por la televisión
y bajo
jaja
aunque todavía no existía un modelo de
negocio claro los inversores estaban
convencidos de que internet era el
futuro así que la competencia por
convertirse en el líder de todos los
buscadores era salvaje ahora bien la
próxima vez que pienses que has cometido
el error de tu vida recuerda a excite
lo más seguro es que ni siquiera sepáis
de quienes estoy hablando verdad pues
bien a finales de los años 90 excite era
uno de los portales más importantes de
internet con su propio buscador un
servicio de correo electrónico y un
montón de cosas más
en 1999 page y brin quisieron vender su
google a excite por nada menos que 750
mil euros al mes así habéis oído bien ni
siquiera llegaba al millón sin embargo
los genios que tomaban las decisiones en
el site declinaron la oferta y no fueron
los únicos porque yahoo hizo exactamente
lo mismo
[Música]
ambas empresas sabían que el algoritmo
de google ofrecía resultados bastante
mejores que los suyos pero con los
algoritmos que ya tenían no les iba nada
mal así que para que cambiara algo ella
funciona tres años más tarde
excite estaba en bancarrota para
entenderlo mejor tenéis que pensar en
toda la disrupción que suponía google en
aquel momento google prioriza los
resultados en función de lo que le
importa al usuario esto puede parecer
una obviedad hoy en día pero en aquel
momento los buscadores priorizaban los
resultados en función de los propios
intereses de la empresa
pero no sólo eso google era el único
buscador que sólo servía para eso para
buscar tanto yahoo como otros buscadores
trataban de ofrecer un todo en uno para
que te quedaras en su web el máximo
tiempo posible
mnoticias el tiempo y hasta videojuegos
en otras palabras google ofrecía un
producto mucho mejor para los usuarios y
los usuarios recompensarán a google con
su confianza de hecho el eslogan que
resume la filosofía de esta empresa y
que se puede ver en todas sus oficinas
es donde vi
es decir no seas malo y no te conviertas
en una de esas grandes empresas
desalmadas hecho a día de hoy google es
una de las empresas que mejor trata a
sus empleados si queréis saber lo que es
un desayuno de lujo hacemos amigos de
alguien que trabaja en google porque en
vuestra vida habéis visto un buffet
libre más amplio y más potente lo cierto
es que esta fórmula les ha funcionado
hasta nuestros días cuando google salió
a bolsa en el año 2004 sus acciones
valían 85 dólares ya era una empresa
equiparable a fort con una
capitalización bursátil de 23 mil
millones de dólares pues bien hoy en día
hablamos de un billón de dólares y si
billones en español en inglés sería
trillion y qué es lo que hizo google
para crecer tanto pues como sabéis hoy
en día google es todo un conglomerado
que ofrece todo tipo de servicios tiene
el navegador más usado del mundo
servicios en la nube y por supuesto este
servicio
google compró youtube por 1650 millones
de dólares
en definitiva google ha cambiado
totalmente como usamos internet y seamos
claros lo ha cambiado a mejor sin ir más
lejos youtube ha conseguido lo que
ninguna televisión pública ha conseguido
que el contenido de divulgación y
educativo llegue a millones de personas
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando todos
claro fonseca es normal que pienses así
google literalmente te ha cambiado la
vida no os preocupéis porque ahora vamos
a ver qué problema puede generar el
hecho de que google sea tan grande
[Música]
el abuso de poder uno no se convierte en
una empresa de un billón de dólares sin
ganarse algún que otro enemigo uno de
los primeros fue nada más y nada menos
que francia cuando salió googlebooks el
gobierno de francia se negó a que una
empresa extranjera digitalizar a su
patrimonio cultural así que francia
presionó a bruselas para que crearan una
versión estatal de 'google books'
europea
y la verdad es que este proyecto ha
salido bastante mal otros enemigos de
google son las empresas tradicionales
cuyo modelo de negocio sale malparado
con internet en este caso tenemos el
ejemplo de los medios españoles contra
google news en 2014 el gobierno de
españa aprobó una ley por la que
portales como google news tendrían que
pagar una tasa a los medios de
comunicación tradicionales para poder
mostrar fragmentos de las noticias es a
lo que google news se dedica lo que
ocurre a continuación y nos sorprende
verlo
google cerrará sitio de noticias en
españa por derechos de autor pero hay
que reconocer que también hay casos
donde si se puede hacer una crítica
legítima a google existen casos donde si
podríamos hablar de posición dominante
en el mercado y uno de esos casos es
google maps que crea su servicio de
mapas en 2005 pero claro antes de este
momento ya había un montón de empresas
que ofrecían los mapas en internet que
tú tenías una página web y querías
insertar un mapa con tu dirección podías
contratar a una de estas empresas y esto
lógicamente tenía un coste
pero entonces llega a google y lo pone
gratis automáticamente muchas empresas
de cartografía digital se imputan a la
bancarrota años más tarde ya sin
competidores google maps se vuelve de
pago es decir usar google maps en casa
es gratis pero usar la api de google
maps para una web grande sí que tiene un
coste económico en este caso la francesa
botín cartografía llegó a demandar a
google maps ante el tribunal de comercio
de parís y diréis por qué pues por lo
que se conoce como dumping es decir
aprovechar que eres una empresa muy
grande para poner precios muy bajos
durante un tiempo y arrasar con la
competencia también tenemos el caso de
android google compró android y nc en
2005 hoy 7 de cada 10 dispositivos
móviles que hay en el mundo usan android
[Música]
en este mercado google también es el rey
y esto significa que puede utilizar
todos estos dispositivos para promover
el resto de sus servicios es decir te
compras un móvil android y tienes el
buscador de google en la pantalla
principal el chrome como navegador por
defecto y google play instalado por
defecto
y que tenga otra tienda de aplicaciones
en principio lo podría pasar muy mal
para competir con google solo porque
google tiene en este dominio con android
y este fue precisamente el motivo de la
multa de más de 4 mil millones de
dólares que la comisión europea le puso
a google en el año 2018 o algo parecido
pasa con google shopping si compráis un
producto en google la primera franja
está que os aparece son los productos
que venden el propio google y por eso
tanto europa como estados unidos están
poniendo tantas demandas a esta empresa
de hecho la demanda del departamento de
justicia contra google es la más
importante en el sector desde el caso
microsoft en 1998
además si este caso contra google
prospera también tendrá consecuencias
directas para otras empresas de las big
tex como amazon facebook o apple y
diréis que es lo peor que puede ocurrir
pues bien según él pierde lo más fácil
sería ponerle una multa como ya lo hizo
la comisión europea pero en este caso la
pregunta es hasta qué punto una multa
afecta realmente una empresa tan
gigantesca como google
en el otro extremo tenemos las
propuestas más populistas propuestas
como la de la senadora estadounidense
elisabeth warren
[Música]
elizabeth warren dice que quiere romper
amazon google y facebook
esta mujer propone separar google en
varias empresas de nuevo no sería la
primera vez que ocurre algo así el gran
precedente fue at&t el gran gigante de
la telefonía en eeuu en 1984 la
obligaron a dividirse en pequeñas
empresas conocidas como las baby first
[Música]
el problema el problema es que estas
medidas primero violan los derechos de
propiedad pero no sólo es muy
probablemente las empresas que surgieran
de la atomización de google terminarían
siendo monopolios en sus respectivos
verticales así que no habríamos
solucionado ningún problema la opción
más probable dentro de las que se están
barajando podría ser que eeuu obligar a
google a compartir su plataforma y
algunos de sus algoritmos con los
competidores y aquí es donde llega la
pregunta con la que empezamos el vídeo
de verdad es imposible competir con
google si alguien diera un servicio
mejor como os podéis imaginar google
dice que si sus abogados defienden que
si las empresas de alphabet han llegado
a donde están es única y exclusivamente
porque son mejores y que cualquiera
podría competir con ellos y es probable
que la respuesta la tengamos dentro de
muy pocos
empresas tecnológicas como spotify o los
creadores de four night quieren reformar
las tiendas de aplicaciones es muy
probable que varias empresas
tecnológicas terminen uniéndose para
crear su propio competidor de google
play y de la app store de apple
estas empresas se quejan de las
comisiones que tienen que pagar para
estar en las tiendas de aplicaciones y
tal vez saquen su propia alternativa en
este momento veremos cómo de fácil es
competir en un segmento tan importante
como el de los market place de
aplicaciones para móviles
[Música]
y mientras tanto la pregunta es para
vosotros creéis que las multas europeas
a google son justas de verdad fomentan
la competencia y la creatividad o
realmente el problema de google es que
todavía nadie ha encontrado la fórmula
para poder competir con su buscador en
definitiva porque todos usamos google
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que aquí en visual politics sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribirse a este canal y darle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si se ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]